une deuxième visite en europe depuis le
début de la guerre en ukraine justin
trideau arrive avec un message pour ses
alliés week-end nantes et ukraine
d'armes
au parlement européen un appel à la
solidarité la meilleure arme des pays
occidentaux contre l'agresseur russe et
l'unité dit le premier ministre ce sont
les fondements de la démocratie qui sont
en jeu nous devons soutenir les
démocraties partout à travers le monde
incluant les plus fragiles et lutter
contre l'autoritarisme
l'occident doit faire plus pour
l'ukraine dit il bonifier l'aide
humanitaire et l'envoi d'armes nous
devons appuyer les gens courageux comme
le prise dans un lenski et les
ukrainiennes qui luttent pour leurs
droits il conclut en citant son
homologue ukrainien la lumière dit il
light
of day l'emportera sur la noirceur
mais au delà des grands discours c'est
surtout l'occasion pour justin trudeau
d'enchaîner les tête à tête avec des
leaders européens ont aussi parlé des
sanctions sans précédent est posé sur
poutine c'est aussi l'occasion de
réaffirmer la force de notre métier une
offensive politique ou le canada tente
de prouver sa pertinence au canada dans
cette crise c'est certainement d'être ce
pays qui aident à faire le pont entre
l'europe et les états unis est
certainement si les britanniques mais le
moment de vérité viendra autour de la
table de l'otan judy un sommet
extraordinaire des leaders de l'alliance
en compagnie du président américain au
menu nouvelles sanctions
une présence renforcée de l'otan en
europe de l'est est l'occasion surtout
de lancer un sérieux avertissement à
vladimir poutine et nihous en cas
d'utilisation d'armes chimiques en
ukraine prévient le secrétaire général
de l'otan changerait complètement la
nature du conflit lors de ce sommet
extraordinaire le canada et ses alliés
de l'otan nous devons surtout prouver
que leurs paroles vont aussi se traduire
en action encore plus musclé pour
freiner l'agression russe la pression
est grande entre les attentes du peuple
ukrainien et le risque pour l'occident
tente d'entrer en confrontation directe
avec la russie ici louis blouin
radio-canada bruxelles